i was like four years or maybe four and
a half and i was introduced to chess
rules because my grandpa and my uncle
used to play a lot and of course it was
like curious what you guys doing
his hand
always was raised
because he had a lot of questions he was
very curious during all school he was
very attentive very serious
and of course his favorite subject in
primary school was a chess lesson
because he could play chess very well at
this moment
and he explained
his classmates
some chess combinations
helped them to solve chess puzzles and
helped the teacher
um
[Applause]
winner of
world chess
championship when he was only 11
i realized
that he would become
one of the best in the world
because his
tremendous willpower
his hard work and of course his chess
talent helped him to achieve such
success i think there are a lot of
brilliant players but i think the one
who sticks out to me as
a genius the most is probably yandere
ponyoshi who
has i think most people will know the my
opponent for the world championship
match i
don't believe in genius to tell the
truth i believe in work as i said i
believe in talent uh in in his private
life
he's
again live full guy
he loves partying he loves
social stuff he loves sports he's both
talented and hard working and i really
think that it's a great example for all
all the kids and all the teens in the
world that success never comes alone
well probably more time you spent more
motivated you get yeah because uh i
believe uh
even uh after i entered let's say the
elite
group of players yeah i believe okay i
crossed this 2700 in 2010 or something
i can't say that i did a lot of chess
work and
just i did a lot of different stuff and
as well like
video games and so on so i was almost
almost you know a semi-pro in in dota
and i had you know a lot of other
hobbies but you know quite recently
maybe like for that for the last few
years i just
tried to focus uh my
attention and uh my energy on on just
work and try to improve
if we speak about his
qualities that have made him to become
the greatest in the world
i think the first is of course chess
talent then hard work then extraordinary
memory
extraordinary logic of course
extraordinary thinking
extraordinary train of thought
non-standard
solving
and his ability to focus on the main
thing
his ability to calculate situation a few
steps forward
uh
i mean in general in life and especially
in sports you shouldn't be satisfied
with what you have at the moment you
should aim for more
of course i am proud
of him
and see him fulfill his potential and
see now how he fight to become the
champion of the world